worum geht es geht darum im Irak zu
stabilisieren und auch die terrormiliz
islamischer Staat am Wiedererstarken zu
hindern zwar ist
genau ich wollte jetzt noch weiteres
erzählen aber das muss ich gar nicht
denn das wird die erste Rednerin tun
Sarah Nanni von Bündnis 90 den Grünen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren sehr geehrte Vertreter
der werbeauftragten die Präsidentin hat
es gerade vorgelesen wir beraten heute
über den Einsatz bewaffneter deutscher
Streitkräfte Stabilisierung sichern
wieder erstarken ist die erst verhindern
Versöhnung im Irak fördern oder wie wir
es nennen das irakmandat dabei ist das
viel zu kurz gegriffen und 280
Soldatinnen sind in sechs Standorten in
vier Ländern in Einsatz die Bundeswehr
leistet ihren Beitrag im Rahmen der
internationalen Einsätze nato-mischen
Irak und der ant-operation in herrent
resolve Schwerpunkt des deutschen
Anteils ist die Beratung der Führung der
irakischen Streit und Sicherheitskräfte
auf strategischer Ebene mit dem Ziel
eben jene zu befähigen
und sie sind es die dafür sorgen dass
der is nicht wieder Fuß fassen kann im
Irak
der Einsatz findet auch im Kontext des
zivilen Engagement von VN und EU statt
die mit der United Nations assistant
Mission Irak und der eu-assistance
Mission Irak vertreten sind die
sicherheitspolitische und die
innenpolitische Lage ist mehr als
kompliziert das sagt auch der
überprüfungsbericht der Bundesregierung
der nun erstmals im Parlament vorgelegt
wurde dort heißt es ich zitiere auch
wenn is aktuell keine akute strategische
Bedrohung für Irak darstellt ist die
Terrororganisation weder besiegt noch
nachhaltig eingedämmt seit dem Angriff
der USA und seiner Verbündeten in 2003
für uns in Deutschland und Europa das
markanteste Datum der jüngeren
Geschichte des Irak musste das Land sich
enorm Herausforderungen stellen die
größte bleibt es erstarken dass sie erst
in Irak und Syrien
das Undenkbare wurde Realität die Gruppe
islamischer Staat rief im Sommer 2014
das sogenannte Kalifat aus schätzungen
gehen davon aus dass zum Zeitpunkt der
größten raumkontrolle bis zu 12
Millionen Menschen in Irak und Syrien
unter seiner Herrschaft lebten und
leideten in diesem Territorium wurde
gefoltert gemordet Menschen wurden
drangsaliert ein brutales Regime
durchgesetzt insbesondere gegenüber
Minderheiten wie den jesid:innen kannte
der is keine Gnade das sogenannte
Kalifat wurde zum Sehnsuchtsort von
Dschihadisten weltweit
propagandistisch hoch professionell
rekrutierte die Gruppe islamischer Staat
neues Kanonenfutter für seine
zerstörerischen Pläne auch tausende
europäische auch deutsche diadistinnen
reisten an um für das sogenannte Kalifat
zu kämpfen es bleibt auch im Rückblick
Wahnsinn
gut dass das vorbei ist
was nicht vorbei ist sind
ansteckgriffe durch die Gruppe
islamischer Staat und andere Milizen
auch die innenpolitische Lage ist mehr
als herausfordernd in etwa zeitgleich zu
unserer Bundestagswahl wurden in Irak
letztes Jahr Wahlen abgehalten die
Regierungsbildung dauert nun fast ein
Jahr später weiterhin an erst in der
letzten Woche wurde der Präsident Abdul
Latte frachit durch das Parlament
gewählt er hat nun Mohammed hier als
sudali mit der Bildung eines Kabinetts
beauftragt als du Dani steht vor einer
Mammutaufgabe in einer ethnisch pluralen
wenig geübten Demokratie ein Kabinett
zusammenzustellen dass die Gesellschaft
Irak bestmöglich abbildet und
professionell miteinander und für das
Land arbeiten kann an diesem Wochenende
soll das Kabinett vorgestellt werden ich
wünsche viel Erfolg gut dass es endlich
vorangeht
wenn wir Deutsche Soldatinnen in einen
Einsatz schicken dann ist das und die
Formulierung unserer Mandate tragen auch
dazu bei wenn wir ehrlich sind immer mit
sehr hohen Erwartungen an Erfolge
verbunden fast so als wären wir wären
wir es in Deutschland gewohnt dass wenn
der Staat sich was vornimmt dass immer
ohne Probleme und druckschläge auch
gelingt und es ist auch richtig
ambitioniert zu sein es ist richtig zu
hinterfragen welchen Beitrag wir leisten
es ist richtig genau zu überlegen bevor
wir unsere gut ausgebildeten Soldatinnen
in ein potenziell für sie gefährlich ist
Mandat entsenden mein Eindruck ist die
Bundesregierung tut genau das
Deutschland hat einen guten Ruf sowohl
bei der Zentralregierung in Irak als
auch in Erbil und es ist auch ein Teil
unserer globalen Verantwortung dass wir
diesen guten Ruf zum Vorteil Iraks zum
Vorteil der Region und zum Vorteil
Europas nutzen
wir hier im Parlament beschließen dass
Mandat die Regierung setzt es um und an
erster Stelle sind es die Soldatinnen
der Bundeswehr die dies mit hohem
persönlichen Einsatz und einer hohen
Professionalität jeden Tag tun ihnen
gilt unser besonderen unser besonderer
Dank insbesondere in diesen für Irak
sehr herausfordernden Zeiten
liebe Kolleginnen ich bitte Sie auch im
Namen meiner Fraktion heute um
Zustimmung für dieses Mandat
Sarah Nani war das von Bündnis 90 den
Grünen in der Fraktion ist sie
Sprecherin für Sicherheit Frieden und
Abrüstung und für die Unionsfraktion
spricht nun Johann David badepol
CSU-Fraktion wird im Antrag zustimmen
das fällt uns leicht weil wir dieses
Mandat immer befürwortet haben es ist
richtig den Kampf gegen
is-terroristen fortzusetzen es ist
richtig dafür zu sorgen für Stabilität
im Irak zu sorgen flüchtlingsursachen zu
bekämpfen Deutschland hat hier eine
wichtige Rolle und die cdu/csu-fraktion
steht hinter diesem Mandat
sie sehen wir nehmen Verantwortung wahr
dass dies neuerdings auch die Grünen tun
Frau Kollegin Nanni das haben sie
überzeugen dargelegt aber das hätten sie
all die vergangenen Jahre auch schon
machen können also schon auffällig dass
sie jetzt mit einmal zu der Erkenntnis
kommen wie wichtig dieses Mandat ist das
ist in den vergangenen Jahren verloren
gegangen das war das war schon immer
Frau Kollegin Brucker wichtig gegen
Terroristen zu kämpfen und vor allen
Dingen jesidenen zu schützen und das
will ich an der Stelle schon mal sagen
in dieser Region hat der Kampf für
Frauenrechte und der Schutz von Frauen
eine hohe Bedeutung und wer sich für
feministische Außenpolitik einsetzt der
muss sich für die Frauen im Irak
Einsetzen der muss sich für jesidenten
Einsetzen der muss sich übrigens auch
für Iranerinnen einsetzen und da sehen
wir von ihnen überhaupt nicht große
Worte hier ersetzen keine Taten dort
vor Ort dass man dazu Gebiet bleibt
gleich wir werden zwar dafür gewesen den
Luftraum von Syrien einzubeziehen die
Fähigkeiten bleiben erhalten
Luftbetankung bodengestützte Luftraum
Überwachung Teilnahme an FX Flügen aber
auch die Ausbildung von stabsaufgaben
innerhalb des nato-verbundes die
sozialdemokratische Fraktion hat in der
letzten Legislaturperiode hier große
Probleme dass im natorahmen zu tun schön
auch dass dieser Lerneffekt gelungen ist
dass die Sozialdemokraten jetzt auch die
NATO wieder mehr wertschätzen und auch
sagen dass das eine gute Aufgabe der
NATO ist in dieser Region aktiv zu
werden also ich muss sagen der
staatspolitische Bildungsprozess in den
regierungskoalitionsfraktionen
insbesondere bei Grünen und SPD hat
Erfolge gezeitigt Kollege Lechte die FDP
war ja schon immer dafür woran es fehlt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das
möchte ich ausdrücklich bemängeln
ist irgendeine Strategie dieser
Bundesregierung für diese Region wissen
sie der Einsätze sind wichtig der
Bundeswehr sie sind ein notwendiges
Mittel sie sind das letzte Mittel aber
man kann nicht erst den Einsatz machen
und dann mal über eine Strategie für die
Region nachdenken man braucht erst eine
Strategie für den Namen und Mittleren
Osten und dann kann der Einsatz ein
Element davon sein und das ist genauso
in der Sahelzone sie haben für keine der
Konfliktregionen am Rande Europas die
uns bedrohen irgendeine außenpolitische
Strategie und die muss vorgelegt werden
was wir sehen sind
Einzelreisen er reist der
Wirtschaftsminister nach Katar findet
das großartig sich dort zu treffen
Menschenrechte Schutz von Arbeitnehmern
und Arbeitnehmern spielen an der Stelle
mit einmal nicht mehr so eine große
Rolle Abschluss übrigens gleich null
kein Kubikmeter LNG wird von dort hier
ankommen der reist der Bundeskanzler
nach Saudi-Arabien grundsätzlich richtig
Ergebnis die OPEC
drosselt ihre Liefermenge schadet uns
eher bringt große Probleme für die
beiden Administrationen nutzt nur Putin
man sieht sie haben Einzelaktionen die
alle nicht durchdacht sind und es fehlt
jede durchdachte Strategie für den Namen
und Mittleren Osten und das ist doch die
Region aus der nach wie vor die meisten
Flüchtlinge auch in unsere Richtung
kommen und das ist einzufordern und da
muss ich Ihnen wirklich sagen
da ist ihnen das vorgemacht worden die
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel hatte mit
der libyenkonferenz mit dem
eu-türkei-abkommen mit dem e3+3-format
viele Dinge in die Welt gesetzt die es
würdig wären fortgesetzt zu werden und
da bleibt diese Bundesregierung nach wie
vor gefordert wir stimmen heute zu aber
unsere Erwartung ist dass sie auch ein
strategischen Einsatz für diese wichtige
Region endlich formulieren darüber
würden wir dann gerne auch mit Ihnen
diskutieren und das unterstützen
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
Johann Wade Pool hat hier schon die
Zustimmung der Union angekündigt zur
Verlängerung des Bundeswehreinsatzes im
Irak das dürfte den nächsten Redner
Freundin jetzt Schmied aus dem
politischer Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich rede gerne über die
durchdachte Strategie der
Bundesregierung die hinter diesem Mandat
steht wir wissen dass der Irak eine
unverändert hohe Herausforderung hat was
die Sicherheitslage anbelangt und die
damit verbundenen Einschränkungen einer
stabilen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Entwicklung deshalb sind wir
der Auffassung dass gerade weil der Irak
ein potenzieller stabilitätsamt im Nahen
Osten sein kann wir die Mission der
Bundeswehr in Bagdad und in Erbil und
auch das Element der Unterstützung der
Luftwaffe in Jordanien weiter
unterstützen sollten die politische Lage
im Iran ist
gekennzeichnet wurden zerklüfte des
Parlament mit schwieriger
Regierungsbildung aber Frau Nanni hat
angesprochen es ist jetzt immerhin ein
neuer Staatspräsident gewählt worden vom
Parlament es gibt eine
Regierungsmehrheit eine Koalition die
sich gebildet hat und für den Nahen
Osten ist es durchaus ungewöhnlich und
begrüßenswert dass der Ort dieser
politischen machttentfaltung des
Parlament ist und das wollen wir
versucht über die Stärkung von
Institutionen solche regulären Prozesse
der Regierungsbildung hinzubekommen und
ich kann Ihnen sagen dass die
Unterstützung dieser Staatlichkeit auch
über die Absicherung durch die
Bundeswehr Einsätze ein ganz wichtiger
Baustein ist so dass gerade die
politischen Eliten des Irak im Parlament
in der Regierung uns auch noch mal
gespiegelt haben dass sie den Einsatz
der Bundeswehr wünschen wir waren mit
einer kleinen Delegation der SPD im
September vor Ort ob es Parlamentarier
waren ob es reg Stellvertreter waren
klare Ansage dieser Einsatz der
Bundeswehr ist politisch gewollt unsere
Bundeswehrsoldaten und Soldaten sind im
Irak willkommen
wir haben auch ein Evaluierungsbericht
vorgelegt um zu dokumentieren dass die
Bundesregierung den vernetzten Ansatz
gerade auch im Irak verfolgt ein
besonders erfolgreiches Element dieser
Evaluierung ist die Tatsache dass in den
letzten Monaten und Jahren Millionen von
binnen Vertriebenen die vor dem es
geflohen sind zurückkehren konnten und
dass damit humanitäre
hilfeentwicklungshilfe und der
Sicherheitsaspekt Hand in Hand geht es
gibt aus meiner Sicht wenig
Einsatzbereiche wo dieser vernetzte
Ansatz als während der Einsatz seit der
Bundeswehr schon so viele Fortschritte
gesehen hat und deshalb ist gerade im
Sinne des Verständnisses von
menschlicher Sicherheit dieser Einsatz
einer den wir breit unterstützen sollten
ich will aber auch nicht verhindern dass
es sorgen gibt gerade auch aus der Reise
die wir dorthin gemacht haben bringen
wir solche Sachen mit das eine ist die
flüchtlingslage in Syrien wo 10.000
überwiegend syrische und fahren nach
irakische Staatsbürgerinnen und
Staatsbürger sich aufhalten das sind
wahre Brutstätten des Terrorismus viele
dieser
flüchtlingslage in Syrien sind unter
Kontrolle des is und wir können noch so
viel
Militäreinsätze fahren wenn immer wieder
eine neue Generation von Terroristinnen
und Terroristen heranwächst dann kommen
wir aus der spiral der Gewalt nicht
heraus hat müssen wir dem Irak helfen
seine StaatsbürgerInnen Staatsbürger und
möglichst aus diesen Lagern rauszuholen
und in die Gesellschaft im Irak wieder
einzugliedern
der zweite Problempunkt ist die Lage der
Jesiden die Rückkehr nach sinscha einem
angestammten Siedlungsgebiet der
Residenten ist leider noch nicht möglich
und immer nur die Rückkehr Hoffnung
vorzuhalten ist zu wenig wir müssen
damit rechnen dass auf Jahre hinweg
Teile der jesidenten eben nicht in ihre
Heimat zurückkehren können und deshalb
festen Aufenthalt und auch eine
wirtschaftliche und bildungsperspektive
in anderen Gebieten des Nordiraks
brauchen da brauchen wir neue Ansätze in
der Zusammenarbeit mit den irakischen
Behörden diesen Flüchtlingen ein
menschenwürdiges Dasein anzubieten
und schließlich stehen sowohl die
Regionalverwaltung im nordkur im Norden
des Iraks im Kurdistan wie auch die
Zentralregierung im Bagdad vor einer
großen Herausforderung die letzten Jahre
im Irak waren geprägt von dem Einsatz
von Sicherheitskräften der
Wiederherstellung von Sicherheit der
Stärkung der Sicherheitskräfte jetzt
geht es darum den nächsten Schritt zu
gehen die zivilen staatlichen
Institutionen wieder aufzubauen und zu
stärken der Sicherheitsstaat muss zu
einem zivilen Staat werden die
peschmerga im Nordirak müssen
Verwalter werden in den Ministerien in
den staatlichen Verwaltung und lassen
Sie uns das offen benennen im gesamten
Irak ist Korruption ein Riesenproblem
und deshalb ist die Stärkung der
zivilenverwaltung der Unabhängigkeit der
Justiz die Stärkung der Transparenz bei
öffentlichen Auftragsvergaben etwas was
ebenfalls im Rahmen des vernetzten
Ansatzes unbedingt unterstützen soll
sie sehen liebe Kollegen Kollegen es
gibt noch einiges zu tun wir haben klare
Vorstellungen davon wo wir ansetzen
sollten gemeinsam mit unserem Partnern
im Irak wir sind ein geschätzter Partner
dort und deshalb bitte ich um Zustimmung
für dieses Mandat herzlichen Dank
die Bitte von in Nils Schmid hier die
Abgeordneten werden hier nach dieser
Debatte auch namentlich über den Einsatz
im Irak abstimmen und der nächste Redner
ist Jan Nolte steht schon bereit für die
afd-fraktion sitzt er im
Verteidigungsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir lehnen das
hier vorliegende Mandat aus
verschiedenen Gründen ab zum einen ist
dazu nennen die Rechtsgrundlage für den
Einsatz in Syrien selbst die
Bundesregierung beruft sich ja hier zum
einen auf das Selbstverteidigungsrecht
und zum anderen auf eine UN-Resolution
von
2015 beide Rechtsgrundlagen sind heute
aber nicht mehr überzeugend weil sie
noch von einem is ausgehen der über
quasi staatliche Strukturen verfügt und
dieser is meine Damen und Herren ist
seit Jahren besiegt und auch die
Bundesregierung scheint auf diese
Rechtsgrundlagen ja lieber nicht
vertrauen zu wollen denn unsere eigenen
Soldaten dürfen den syrischen Luftraum
seit diesem Jahr nicht mehr verletzen
gleichwohl hat die Bundesregierung
offensichtlich kein Problem damit andere
Staaten durch Luftbetankung dazu zu
befähigen diese Luftraumverletzungen
auch in Zukunft zu begehen wir arbeiten
bei diesem Einsatz mit der Türkei
zusammen die illegale Drohnenangriffe in
Syrien fliegt und Teile des Landes seit
2016 völkerrechtswidrig
vorgestellt und wir arbeiten natürlich
auch mit den USA zusammen die die
Kontrolle über die syrischen Ölfelder
übernommen haben aber meine Damen und
Herren und das gleich klar zu stellen
natürlich handeln die USA hier nur aus
selbstlosen Motiven was denn auch sonst
sie haben nämlich erklärt dass sie sich
das syrische Öl nur genommen haben um es
vor dem is zu beschützen das ist doch
nett von den USA da muss sich der
syrische Staat offenbar freuen meine
Damen und Herren erwarten Sie nicht dass
die Alternative für Deutschland bei
diesem Unrecht gegen ein souverän Staat
auch noch mitmacht wir stimmen mit nein
hier heute der zweite wichtige Punkt ist
die Stabilisierung des Irak und da haben
wir die gleichen Probleme wie bei so
vielen anderen Einsätzen kein klares
Konzept keine echte Erfolgskontrolle und
eine Exit-Strategie gibt es sowieso
nicht die Bundesregierung kann überhaupt
nicht erklären wie sich konkret das
deutsche Engagement der letzten Jahre
auf die Sicherheitslage im Irak
ausgewirkt hat es gab keine echte
Evaluation man weiß nicht was sich
bewährt hat und was ich nicht bewährt
hat und dement kann es auch keine
tragfähige Strategie geben für die
Zukunft die Bundesregierung ist offenbar
damit zufrieden einfach so ihren Beitrag
zu leisten und so ein bisschen im Nebel
herum zu stochern uns reicht das nicht
hier braucht man eine tragfähige
Strategie und die sehen wir nicht und
das liegt auch daran dass die
Sicherheitslage im Irak zu volatil ist
wir wissen doch überhaupt nicht ob die
Soldaten die wir heute ausbilden in
einem Jahr nicht Teil einer Rebellen
oder Terrorgruppe sind die den Irak
weiter die stabilisiert hier dieses
Mandat vorzuführen unter diesen
Bedingungen ist verantwortungslos
und wenn das narrativ bemüht wird dass
die Bundesregierung durch diesen Einsatz
ja letztlich die Sicherheit von uns
allen Schützen würde indem sie
Islamisten in Syrien und dem Irak
zurückdrängt den habe ich einen
Gegenvorschlag wir haben doch jetzt
gerade während ich hier stehe und diese
Rede halte mehr als 600 vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtige Gefährder hier in
Deutschland das sind Menschen denen man
jederzeit zutrauen würde einen
Terroranschlag zu begehen ich würde
sagen wir sprechen dann das nächste Mal
über Islamisten in dem Irak und in
Syrien wenn diese Gefährder endlich aus
Deutschland abgeschoben sind
so dann noch einmal die Frage ist noch
ein Mitglied des Hauses anwesend dass
seine Stimme nicht abgegeben hat
das ist nicht der Fall dann schließe ich
jetzt die Abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu beginnen also die
Abstimmung noch einmal zur Änderung des
stabilisierungsfondsgesetzes zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds weil der
ja ursprünglich zur corona-pandemie
eingerichtet worden war nächster Redner
ist nun für die FDP Ulrich Lechte der
aus dem politische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass Sie Herr Kollege wadeful an diesem
Mandat kaum etwas zu kritisieren
gefunden haben das spricht ja für die
Arbeit der Ampel und
die SPD kann sich in dieser Ampel
endlich
befreit zeigen kann befreit aufspielen
Frau Nanni hat frischen Wind in die
Sicherheitspolitik der Grünen gebracht
aber die Kontinuität der CDU in der
Außenpolitik ist ein echtes Plus für die
Stärke des Parlaments und dafür mein
herzlichen Dank
auch auch wenn unser Fokus derzeit zu
Recht auf die abscheulichen
Kriegsverbrechen in der russischen Armee
in der Ukraine gerichtet ist dürfen wir
auch die schrecklichen Verbrechen der
Terrororganisation islamischer Staat im
Irak und in Syrien nicht vergessen seit
2014 hatten die is-terroristen ganze
Landstriche erobert und dort die
Bevölkerung tyrannisiert besonders die
Gruppe der Jesiden wurde Opfer von
Folter Vergewaltigung Versklavung und
definitiv Völkermord seitdem konnte der
is erfolgreich bekämpft werden und er
ist eben nicht mehr in der Lage Gebiete
zu kontrollieren das ist ein gemeinsamer
Erfolg der lokalen Sicherheitskräfte und
des internationalen Engagements an dem
sich auch Deutschland beteiligt es ist
also auch ein Erfolg unserer Soldatinnen
und Soldaten vielen herzlichen Dank
dafür
aber meine Damen und Herren
trotz dieser Erfolge müssen wir den is
weiterhin als Bedrohung ernst nehmen er
kontrolliert zwar keine Gebiete mehr
aber existiert weiterhin im Untergrund
und verübt Terroranschläge vor allem
gegen kritische Infrastruktur
unvertreter des irakischen Staates das
wirkt sich unmittelbar auf die
Sicherheitslage und das
Sicherheitsempfinden im Land aus
insbesondere Angehörige vom Minderheiten
sind da betroffen so schilderten bei
einer öffentlichen Anhörung des
Menschenrechtsausschusses hier im
Bundestag die Vertreter der jesidischen
Gemeinschaft ihre Furcht erneut Opfer zu
werden diesen Hilferuf dürfen wir nicht
unerhört lassen meine Damen und Herren
auch die irakische Regierung und die
kurdische Regionalregierung bitten um
die Fortsetzung der militärischen
Unterstützung durch internationale
Partner und insbesondere auch die von
Deutschland auch diese Bitte dürfen wir
nicht unerhört lassen denn im Irak gibt
es gute Anzeichen für eine positive
Entwicklung nach einem monatelangen
Machtkampfes abdulativ Rashid zum neuen
Präsidenten des Irak gewählt worden und
eine neue Regierung wird gebildet es hat
sich auch eine aktive Zivilgesellschaft
entwickelt und die Meinungsfreiheit ist
gerade im regionalen Vergleich sehr
weitgehend diese Entwicklung muss vor
den destabilisierungsversuchen der
is-terroristen geschützt werden was auch
für die Fortsetzung des Einsatzes
spricht ist das Ergebnis unseres
überprüfungsberichtes wir als FDP hatten
ja gefordert dass alle
Bundeswehreinsätze evaluiert werden und
dies haben wir als Ampel im
Koalitionsvertrag auch so vereinbart das
Ergebnis sehen Sie nun mit diesem Mandat
liegt im Bundestag zum ersten normal ein
solcher überprüfungsbericht vor vielen
Dank an das Auswärtige Amt und das
Verteidigungsministerium für diesen
Bericht dass es ganz eindeutig eine
Verbesserung unserer
Entscheidungsgrundlage
Verbesserungsvorschläge an Evaluierungen
können natürlich vorgenommen werden aber
der Union sei auch zugerufen wenn so
wenig Zahlen aus euren Gezeiten
vorliegen ist es auch schwierig
vernünftig zu evaluieren dass auch
werden wir erneut richten als Ampel ihr
werdet also falls ihr jemals wieder in
die Verantwortung hier im Hause
zurückkommt einen weitaus besser
geführten Laden fortfinden als wir das
getan haben im vergangenen Dezember
meine Damen und Herren unser Engagement
im Irak beschränkt sich nicht auf den
Einsatz der Bundeswehr der es wichtig
wäre aber allein nicht ausreichend im
Sinne des vernetzten Ansatzes wird
ergänzt durch umfangreiches politisches
und ziviles Engagement dazu gehört die
Stärkung der Fähigkeiten und die Bürger
Nähe der Polizei um die Legitimität
dieser wichtigen Institution für alle
Staaten dieser Welt zu erhöhen die
Ausbildung irakischer Spezialistinnen
und Spezialisten zum Minenräumen ich
habe gerade geändert Liebe grünen
Freunde die Unterstützung von Programmen
für die derekabilisierung und
Reintegration von ehemaligen
is-anhängern die Aufarbeitung von
is-mitteln die psychosoziale
Unterstützung von Opfern vom
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Unterstützung
für Basisgesundheitsversorgung sowie die
Förderung vom Wasser Hygiene und
Sanitärversorgung mit diesem umfassenden
Engagement hat Deutschland dazu
beigetragen dass ein Großteil der
Menschen im Zuge des is-terrors
vertrieben wurden inzwischen in ihre
Heimatgemeinden zurückkehren konnten ein
großer großer Erfolg unsere Hilfe wird
fortgesetzt und dieses ganze
Zusammenwirkung der vielen Maßnahmen
vernetzten Ansatz trägt dazu bei die
Resilienz gegen den is zu fördern und
die eigene Sicherheitsverantwortung
ihrer Akt zu stärken wir bitten Sie
dafür um Zustimmung und daher zu diesen
Mandat vielen Dank
Ulrich Lechte war dass er aus dem
politische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion hat hier noch einmal eben
um zu Stimmung geworben
ergibt oder Punkte wenn man was
besonders richtig macht lieber Kollege
sondern ich gebe viel lieber das Wort
dem Kollegen Jacqueline Nasic der
Kollege also noch mal Komplimente für
das Einhalten der Redezeit nächste
Rednerin ist sagt für die Linksfraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
etwa einem Monat ist es her dass die
15-Jährige sehen ab es haben
Majid al-hazali von einer
US-amerikanischen Kugel in den Kopf
getroffen und getötet wurde das
passierte während die US-Soldaten in der
Nähe eines Wohngebiets trainierten
und unser tiefes Mitgefühl gilt ihren
Hinterbliebenen
die Verantwortlichen dafür gehören aber
zu Rechenschaft gezogen es darf im Irak
keine Verschleierung mehr geben
auf meiner Nachfrage diesbezüglich ans
Auswärtige Amt sagte man es gäbe keine
eigenen Erkenntnisse dazu und wir
erwarten von einer ampelregierung die
nicht nur genders sondern eben auch
Werte basiert und feministisch sich
nennt dass sie alles dafür tut dass der
Tod der jungen seinab aufgeklärt wird
und die Verantwortlichen zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden
und eigentlich auf der Tod der
500.000 unschuldigen irakischen Kinder
die Opfer von westlichen Sanktionen
wurden von denen die
geschäftsunikerinnen der US-Außenpolitik
alright 1 sagte sie seien dem Preis wert
die Madeline Albert die sie noch von dem
Werte basierten Grün vor zwei Jahren zu
ihrer Fraktionsklausur als targast
gefeiert haben schämen sie sich endlich
für nichts
auch dieser Krieg der USA begann mit
einer gigantischen Lüge denn wir wissen
alle dass
Massenvernichtungswaffen von George
Bushs siegreichen Truppen im Irak
niemals gefunden wurden dafür aber das
gesamte gesellschaftliche System
zerschlagen wurde und mit einem teile
und herrsche auf konfessionellen
Kriterien fußendeskorruptionssystem
geschaffen wurde deswegen dauert seit
etwa einem Jahr auch die Regierungskrise
an und genau auch aus diesen
us-verbrechen speiste und speist sich
der fürchterliche is-terror ihr
zuständiger Staatssekretär antwortet auf
Nachfrage dazu die NATO-Truppen würden
Zitat die seit 2014 im Kampf gegen die
is erreichten Erfolge und Fortschritte
konsolidieren und absichern wir alle
wissen dass der is immer noch da ist
dass er noch stärker mittlerweile wieder
ist und das mindestens 10.000 is-kämpfer
in Irak und Syrien sich der nicht
aufhalten und in Syrien
wächst eine neue Generation von
Terroristen heran allein am Lager allhoi
aus dem sie sich übrigens seit Jahren
weigern radikalisierte deutsche
Staatsbürger zurückzunehmen wachsen
täglich neue Terroristen heran meine
Damen und Herren hören Sie endlich auf
sich als Lakai von gescheiterten
us-abenteuern aufzuspielen hören sie auf
dafür Steuergelder und vor allen Dingen
das Leben von deutschen Soldaten zu
riskieren
dass man da widerspricht übrigens
ausdrücklich dem Willen des irakischen
Parlaments das 2020 alle ausländischen
Truppen aufgefordert hat das Land zu
verlassen die Linke lehnt dass man dort
ab
Jacqueline elastisch war das ob Frau im
Verteidigungsausschuss und auch
menschenrechtspolitische Sprecherin
Abstimmung bekannt es geht um den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktionen der
cdu/csu zur dritten Beratung des
Gesetzentwurfs der Fraktion SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und FDP zum Entwurf eines
Gesetzes zu Änderungen des
stabilisierungsfondsgesetzes zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
abgegeben wurden 644 Stimmkarten mit ja
haben 168 gestimmt mit Nein 415 es gab
61 Enthaltungen damit ist der
Entschließungsantrag abgelehnt
eine gute Idee dieser
Entschließungsantrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion war das
Schriftführern und den Assistenten zu
danken die dafür sorgen dass hier Tag
und Nacht auch namentliche Abstimmung
ausgezählt werden
und der Kollege Dr Norbert Röttgen hat
jetzt das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte die Kritik des
Kollegen wadeful aufgreifen
das ist der Bundesregierung an einer
Konzeption an einer Strategie für den
Irak fehlt ja das kritisiert beanstandet
wir haben es übrigens schon in der in
der in der Debatte um den letzten Antrag
beanstandet und aufgefordert hier
nachzuliefern ich möchte festhalten dass
keine Rednerinnen und kein Redner aus
den Koalitionsfraktionen auf diese
inhaltliche Kritik das ist keine
irak-konzeption und irak-strategie in
der deutschen Außenpolitik gibt auch nur
mit einem Satz geantwortet hat nichts
ist gekommen dazu und das ist eine
ziemlich dramatische Feststellung denn
die Stabilisierung des Irak ist ein
wesentlicher Baustein für die
Stabilisierung der gesamten Region
Ratlosigkeit können wir uns nicht
leisten weil es ist unser Interesse dass
diese Region stabilisiert wird wir haben
es ja erlebt und darum können wir nicht
einfach nur nicht wissen was irgendwie
zu tun ist wir sehen es auf dramatische
Weise jetzt im Iran auch dort ist die
Politik dieser Bundesregierung und der
Europäischen Union
Ratlosigkeit gekennzeichnet es ist unser
Interesse es ist die europäische
Möglichkeit das die europäische
Verantwortung in dieser Region für
Stabilisierung zu sorgen die Amerikaner
werden es nicht tun sie haben auch die
Autorität dazu verloren wir Europäer
Tunis oder wir werden mit den Folgen der
Instabilität bei uns in Europa
konfrontiert wird
und unsere Kritik ist dass sie das dem
Bundeswehreinsatz benutzen missbrauchen
als ein Alibi und als einen Ersatz für
nicht vorhandene Politik und politische
Strategie ist ein Missbrauch der
Bundeswehr
und unsere Kritik zum zweiten
bezieht sich auf die
den schlampigen Umgang auch den
verfassungsrechtlich problematischen
Umgang mit der Parlamentsbeteiligung das
ist ja ein besonderer Fall dass das
Parlament aus dem politischen Verhalten
zustimmt ein besonderer Fall in unserer
Verfassung und der Umgang der
Bundesregierung mit dem Parlament und
den sich aus diesem aus dieser
besonderen
verantwortungsteilung zwischen Exekutive
und Legislative ergebenden Fragen wird
die Bundesregierung nicht gerecht
die Bundesregierung hat bislang nicht
überzeugend begründet warum dieser
Einsatz überhaupt mandatspflichtig ist
ich zitiere die
bundesverteidigungsministerin aus der
einbringungsdebatte Zitat ich sage es
noch mal deutlich es geht um eine
Beratung durch unsere Soldaten
mandatspflichtig wird aber ein Einsatz
erst wenn die qualifizierte Erwartung
damit verbunden ist dass es zu
bewaffneten Auseinandersetzungen kommt
der Nachweis ist nicht geführt worden
sie müssen dem Parlament gegenüber
begründen dass es ein mandatspflichtiges
Verhältnis hier gibt oder eben nicht
Herr Kollege möchten Sie die
Zwischenfrage des Kollegen der Stationen
lassen bitte sehr
Herr Dr Röttgen ich bin ein wenig
irritiert ob ihrer Rede da hat eins die
Verhältnisse im Nahen Osten zu
mindestens bezüglich Iran den sie
erwähnt haben seit der Revolution im
Iran schon sehr sehr schwierig sind da
war ich gerade zwei Jahre alt das heißt
sie haben bei der Revolution 79 wo wir
komeni runtergeflogen haben und seit 79
haben Sie vermutlich mehr Verantwortung
in der bundesrepublikanischen Politik
getragen wie ich sie waren im
vergangenen Periode der Vorsitzende des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses und erzählen
heute dass dieses Mandat eigentlich
nicht mandatierungswillig wäre also ich
komme gerade nicht mehr mit ob dieser
Tatsache dass sie uns heute als
Bundesregierung Dinge vorwerfen die
offensichtlich schon ihre Wurzeln in den
letzten Perioden hatten wo sie in den
verantwortungsvollen Positionen waren
der auswärtige Ausschuss ist derjenige
welche der sich um Mandate kümmert und
ich habe solche Kritik von ihnen als
Vorsitzenden des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
nie zur Kenntnis genommen könnten Sie
dazu kurz Stellung nehmen
ich nehme dazu ich nehme
dazu gerne Stellung also erstens finde
ich es völlig legitim und richtig dass
man fragt was ist an Fehlern passiert
auch in der Vergangenheit es gibt uns
eine Vergangenheit von zehn Jahren von
20 Jahren das haben auch
unterschiedliche Parteien dort regiert
manche regieren auch immer noch das ist
völlig legitim aber dass das eine
Plattitüde wird in der Reaktion der
Koalition auf Kritik wenn sie jetzt
etwas falsch machen und Fehler sich
leisten dass sie dann sagen aber ihr
habt ja auch in der Vergangenheit
regiert sie müssen zu den Fehlern und
den Entscheidungen von heute
selbstständig stehen und nicht immer nur
mit einem Reflex auf die Vergangenheit
beantworten
ich bin noch nicht genau ich wollte das
nur zu der reflexhaftigkeit
wie Sie Antworten auf Kritik an ihrer
heut an ihrer heutigen Politik anmerken
das ist gerade der Punkt der Kollege
Lechte dieses Mandat hat sich
grundlegend gewandelt das genau der
Punkt dieses Mandat hat gestartet als
die Grünen ist noch abgelehnt haben als
ein ant-mandat mit der militärischen
Bekämpfung des islamischen Staates der
territoriale macht im Irak auch in
Syrien errungen hatte so ist dieses
Mandat gestartet und die Veränderung
liegt darin dass im Ende des letzten
Jahres also zu der Zeit als die Ampel
schon regiert auch die sogenannte
Koalition der Willigen den militärischen
Kampf gegen den islamischen Staat
eingestellt hat darum sagt die
bundesverteidigungsministerin
richtigerweise
unsere Soldaten machen dort Beratung das
ist heute nicht mehr der Kampfeinsatz
der es war der ist erfolgreich
abgeschlossen worden aber sie segeln
immer noch unter dieser Flagge des
anti-smandates das ist eben genau unsere
Kritik es ist inhaltlich etwas ganz
anderes geworden aber sie stehen nicht
dazu sie sagen das nicht sondern sie
benutzen es als ein Alibi von nicht
vorhandener Irak Politik das ist genau
die Kritik und das ist genau die
Veränderung die sich in ihrer
Regierungszeit vollzogen wird
ihre reguläre Redezeit beträgt jetzt
noch einige Sekunden einige Sekunden sie
nehmen zweitens das ist wirklich zu
beanstanden in inhaltlich unzutreffender
Weise die Autorität des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts für ihre für
eine grundsätzliche Streitfrage in
Anspruch sie behaupten das
Bundesverfassungsgericht habe bestätigt
es handelt es sich hier um ein
systemkollektiver Sicherheit das ist die
verfassungsrechtliche Voraussetzung für
die Legalität dieses Einsatzes das ist
nicht der Fall das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es nicht in
der Sache entschieden und dass sie das
die Autorität des Verfassungsgerichts
missbrauchen und gegenüber dem Parlament
manipulativ etwas Falsches behaupten ist
ein inakzeptabler schlampiger
hoffentlich vielleicht aber auch
manipulativer Umgang mit der Wahrheit
gegenüber diesem Parlament und das
beanstanden wir Unzulänglichkeit im
Handwerk drückt sich aus den
Unzulänglichkeit von Politik
Norbert Röttgen war das mit sehr
deutlicher Kritik an der
bundesverteidigungsministerin Christine
Lamprecht die hier auf der
Regierungsbank auch den Reden folgt
allerdings ist selber nicht sprechen
wird wir haben noch zwei Räder auf der
Liste aber
da zählt sie nicht dazu natürlich wird
sie aber auch abstimmen denn da auch das
wurde ja hier deutlich gemacht die
Bundeswehr ist eine parlamentarmee und
wird nur im Ausland tätig wenn der
Bundestag sie damit beauftragt Christian
klingt jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Dichter
Mutti ebenias schrieb einst über seine
Heimatstadt Bagdad ich zitiere mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidentin es war morgen
in Bagdad und wir zechten unsere Gläser
waren wie wirbelnde Sterne über unseren
Köpfen Kronen aus golden Jasmin eben IAS
schrieb dies zur Blütezeit Bagdads etwa
zur Zeit Carls des großen als die
westliche abendländische Geschichte
begann zu diesem Zeitpunkt war es schon
etwa 1.000 Jahre her dass Alexander in
Babylon eingezogen war und es war 4000
Jahre her dass die Summe Rinnen und
Sumerer im Zweistromland damit begann
das fruchtbare Land zu bewirtschaften
meine Damen und Herren der heutige Irak
ist eines der ältesten Siedlungsgebiete
der Menschheit er könnte aufgrund seiner
natürlichen Ressourcen und der Begabung
seiner Menschen ein wohlhabendes Land
sein doch die Situation ist dort oftmals
schwierig ethnische und religiöse
Bruchlinien bestehen fort lange Zeit
wurde um die Regierungsbildung gerungen
und doch gibt es Fortschritte und es
gibt Hoffnung die höchsten Staatsämter
wurden neu besetzt es bilden sich
Ansätze eines demokratischen
Parteiensystems auf echter politischer
Grundlage über ethnisch religiöse
Grenzen hinweg die in irakischen
Sicherheitskräften gelingt es immer
besser im Land für Sicherheit zu sorgen
das zeigt der überprüfungsbericht den
die Ampelkoalition auf den Weg gebracht
hat wir ampelparteien halten es für
wichtig dass man Date geprüft werden das
ist ein echter Fortschritt im
Regierungshandeln wenn das schon früher
Standard gewesen wäre hätten wir uns
eine Menge Ärger erspart
meine Damen und Herren die Ziele des
irak-einsatzes sind realistisch ein
Beitrag zur Stabilisierung der Region zu
leisten insbesondere durch den
fähigkeitsaufbau der Streit und
Sicherheitskräfte damit die neue
Regierung handeln kann damit die
Wirtschaft sich erholen kann damit
Kinder zur Schule gehen können benötigt
der Irak vor allem eines er braucht
Sicherheit das Sicherheit die Grundlage
von allem ist zeigt sich zeigen die
kurdischen Autonomiegebiete in dem sich
im Schutz der Sicherheitskräfte ein
lebendiges wirtschaftliches und
gesellschaftliches Leben entwickelt hat
unser gemeinsames Ziel lautet ein
vergleichbares Sicherheitsversprechen
auf den gesamten Irak zu übertragen wenn
gute Regierungsführung Volksbildung und
weitere Demokratisierung folgen wird der
Irak ein sehr positiven Weg gehen
ein solches freiheitliches und
zivilisiertes Gesellschaftsmodell wäre
für die gesamte Region attraktiv doch
ein solches Modell hat auch Feinde der
sogenannte islamische Staat ist im Irak
nach wie vor aktiv und wir müssen ihm
weiterhin entschieden entgegentreten und
das rückständige und brutale molaregime
im Iran verfolgt das Ziel den Irak zu
destabilisieren Geld Propaganda
Drohnenangriffe Raketenbeschuss der Iran
setzt alle Mittel ein das iranische
Regime hat mit dem brutalen Mord an Maße
armini und vielen anderen Menschen auf
schändlichste Weise gezeigt dass es
längst jede Legitimität verloren hat mit
unserer Entscheidung für des Mandat
zeigen wir wir lassen den mullas
Übergriffe auf den Irak nicht durchgehen
wir stehen an der Seite des Irak
in diesem Zusammenhang war mein
Vorredner von der AFD wohl nicht völlig
transparent sehr geehrter Herr Nolte
völkerrechtliche Vorbehalte gegen das
Mandat sind unbeachtlich mir drängt sich
vielmehr die Frage auf ob die Gründe für
die Ablehnung ihrer Fraktion nicht darin
liegen dass der Iran ein enger
Verbündeter für dem Angriffskrieg Putins
gegen die Ukraine ist und dass die
politische Nähe ihrer Fraktion zu Putin
in dieser Frage mittlerweile
handlungsleitend geworden ist die AFD
gibt ein verheerendes Bild ab nicht nur
in der Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
meine Damen und Herren niemand von uns
fällt es leicht unsere Soldatin und
Soldaten in einen Auslandseinsatz zu
schicken und sie für Monate von ihren
Familien zu trennen ich weiß dass sie
alle diese Verantwortung sehr ernst
nehmen deswegen bekräftige ich der
Auftrag der Bundeswehr im Irak ist
sinnvoll er ist legitim und die
Bundeswehr erfüllt ihn gut der Dienst
unserer Soldatinnen und Soldaten
verdient die allergrößte Anerkennung
meine Damen und Herren ein letzter
Gedanke wenn wir heute auf den Irak
schauen stellen sich Fragen die so alt
sind wie die ersten Hochkulturen wie
können wir Sicherheit für alle schaffen
und wie kann es gelingen die Ressourcen
der Natur so gut und nachhaltig zu
nutzen dass alle Menschen ein gutes
Leben führen können das sind Grundfragen
der Menschheitsgeschichte ja des
Menschseins an sich und vor diesem
Grundfragen sind wir alle gleich wenn
wir auf den Irak schauen wir auch auf
uns selbst deswegen sagen wir gegen
irakerinnen und Irakern wir stehen an
eurer Seite ihr könnt euch selbst helfen
ihr könnt euch eine gute Zukunft
aufbauen und bei eurer
selbsthilfeunterstützen wir euch
Deutschland steht an der Seite des Irak
im Sinne der Freiheit im Sinne der
Zivilisation und im Sinne der
Menschlichkeit deswegen stimmen wir dem
Mandat zu
thomas fröbekamp hat jetzt das Wort für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die letzten
Wochen und Monate haben uns in der
verteidigungs- und Sicherheitspolitik
ganz maßgeblich beschäftigt mit dem
verbrecherischen Angriffskrieg Russlands
auf die Ukraine und den Folgen wir haben
gemeinsam in der Mitte dieses Parlaments
dazu wichtige Entscheidungen getroffen
zur Finanzierung und besseren
Ausstattungen unserer Bundeswehr wir
sind gemeinsam auch als cdu/csu-fraktion
mit der Regierung dabei die bündnis- und
Verteidigungspolitik in der NATO neu
auszurichten es werden Maßnahmen
ergriffen um unsere Truppenstärke an der
Ostflanke der NATO zu verstärken das
alles ist richtig und selbstverständlich
auch mit Unterstützung unserer Fraktion
Erfolg ich sage das an dieser Stelle
ganz bewusst weil all diese Maßnahmen
machen wir in der Mitte des Parlaments
ohne die Ränder des Parlaments weder die
Linken noch die AFD haben diesen
notwendigen Maßnahmen für die Bewahrung
unserer Sicherheit Arbeit und die
Verteidigung unserer Freiheit zugestimmt
sie haben sich aus der Verantwortung
gedrückt und das tun sie auch bei dieser
internationalen Verantwortung meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wir dürfen
nicht auf den Augen verlieren dass neben
der notwendigen Verteidigung unseres
Landes an den Außengrenzen der NATO
selbstverständlich unsere Frieden und
unsere Freiheit auch bedroht sind in
anderen Regionen dieser Welt natürlich
unverändert auch durch den islamischen
Staat ja es mag sein dass die
kriegerische Auseinandersetzung die
verfestigten Strukturen des islamischen
Staats überwunden sind aber nach
un-berichten halten sich noch immer
10.000 is-kämpfer im Irak und in Syrien
auf und das tun sie nicht nur um vor Ort
für Unruhe zu kämpfen es ist deswegen im
nationalen Sicherheitsinteresse das auch
an der Südflanke der NATO wir unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit sicherstellen es
ist notwendig und unverzichtbar dass wir
uns auch weiter an internation anderen
Missionen und insbesondere an diesem
Einsatz im Irak beteiligen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
wir als cdu/csu-fraktionen Stimmen
deswegen der Fortsetzung dieses Mandates
trotz der in den Vorreden geäußerten
rechtlichen und inhaltlichen Bedenken zu
weil wir sie in der Sache für richtig
halten lassen Sie mich an dieser Stelle
aber noch einmal auch an die Adresse der
SPD sagen die sich jetzt ja nun Rüben
dieser Einsatz sei das erste Mal
evaluiert worden meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ich gehe davon aus und
nehmen das für unsere Fraktion in
Anspruch dass wir keiner einzigen
Mandatsverlängerung in diesem Haus
zugestimmt haben von der wir nicht
überzeugt waren dass die Evaluation die
Fortsetzung dieses Einsatzes für
zwingend erforderlich gehalten hat das
haben wir immer so getan auch bevor
diese Regierung die Verantwortung
übernommen
und lassen Sie mich ein letztes Wort an
die Flügel dieses Parlamentes richten
die ja sehr bemüht waren eine
inhaltliche Begründung für die Ablehnung
der Zuschauer für die Fortsetzung dieses
Mandats zu finden die Wahrheit ist doch
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
von den Linken in ihrer Programmatik
sind Sie grundsätzlich gegen
Auslandseinsätze der Bundeswehr und
deswegen sind sie gegen diesen Einsatz
und all ihre Bemühungen irgendwelche
Begründungen dazu für dazu zu finden
sind fadenscheinig und nicht glaubwürdig
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wenn Sie dagegen sind sagen Sie es
einfach sie wollen die NATO abschaffen
sie wollen die Bundeswehr Einsätze auf
das an den internationalen Missionen
begrenzen und dann sagen Sie es hier das
gilt übrigens auch für die AFD auch sie
wollen grundsätzlich keine
Auslandseinsätze der Bundeswehr dann
sagen Sie es doch hier einfach anstatt
irgendwelche verschwurbelten Erklärungen
zu finden wir stimmen zu meine Damen